-I want to talk, obviously
about what's happened
the last few days with Iran.
You know, I think
one of the questions is,
obviously, you have this country
that, you know,
is a sovereign nation
but in many ways a bad actor
How do you -- would you
go about, if you were president,
trying to deescalate
the current situation with Iran?
-Well, you know, the first job
of the President of the United
States is to keep America safe
And this President has gone in
exactly the opposite direction
and he started in
three years ago
when he tore up
the Iran nuclear deal
that Iran had agreed not
to advance its nuclear program
Our allies wanted America
to stay in it,
but instead, Donald Trump
tore it up.
And he's just had
a series of escalating attacks
And now with the killing
of Soleimani, we're in a place
where we've stopped our action
against ISIS.
We now have a president who is
tweeting threats of war crimes
We've had to pull all of
the Americans out of the area,
all the civilians.
This is not
making America safer.
And what it's really doing, we
really have to talk about this
this is moving us closer
to the very edge of war.
Americans don't want
a war with Iran.
And this is the moment
Americans need to speak up
need to speak up loudly
and say no more war
in the Middle East.
It's time to have
peace in the Middle East.
We need to get out of this
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It does seem like
we're living in an era
where there is an expansio
of presidential powers.
You know, Congress has les
to say about what wars we're in,
how those wars are fought.
And, you know, from Presiden
Obama to President Trump,
a lot of what they ran on
was no more wars,
which has not been the case.
How do you as President
actually go about,
you know, keeping
a campaign promise
that has been made now
a couple of times
about we're not going
to do this anymore?
-Well, part of it is
you have to think about
the use of our military.
We have the finest militar
on earth.
All three of my brothers
served in the military.
Our military will do
anything we ask them to do
They will make any sacrifice
But that means the Commander
in Chief has to understand
that we should not
ask our military
to try to solve problems tha
cannot be solved militarily.
We have to be willing
to use our diplomatic tools.
We have to be willing to use
our economic tools.
We have to be willing
to work with our allies.
We have to be willing to d
the quiet, careful work
of back channels
to work together.
Remember, Iran, yes, a natio
that takes many bad acts.
But working with our allies,
we got them to
the negotiating table.
We got them to agree to give u
advancing their nuclear program.
We can make diplomacy work
but it's hard work.
It's painstaking work. But it'
something I will be committed to
as Commander in Chief.
-I want to ask you
about this, as well.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We've actually had --
Some of your --
I believe multiple
former students of yours
are actually in Congress now
We've had some of them
on the show.
Is it --
-Katie Porter.
-Katie Porter was here.
-She was on not so long ago.
She's fab.
-She's fabulous.
And very well prepared
when she -- when she questions
people in front of Congress.
-Katie's always well prepared.
-That's good.
Was is it important as a student
in Elizabeth Warren --
Professor Warren's class
to be well prepared?
-Oh, yes, if you wanted
to get out with your life.
-Yeah.
-Uh-huh. Yeah.
-What's a worst-case scenari
hypothetically
for a student in one of your
classes who is unprepared?
I mean, is there a way
to sit in the back
and just not get called on
-Ask Joe Kennedy that question
-Oh, Joe Kennedy.
[ Audience "oh"s ]
Didn't go well for Joe Kennedy
[ Laughter ]
-Uh, it was --
-What's it like --
I mean, you must be proud --
-That first day at law schoo
was his whole life
in front of him.
Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, see, that's why --
See, I wouldn't even go
to law school for that reason.
That's sounds so terrifying.
-But it was fun.
-And is it fun
running into former students
as colleagues now?
-See, you know, I think of thi
as one of these big division
between Donald Trump and me.
The people from my former life
are really rising stars
in public service.
And the people
from Donald Trump's former lif
are rising stars in prison
-Yeah, that's a difference
-It's --
-That's a difference, yeah
-It's a thing.
-That's a considerable
difference.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It seems like, obviously,
it's been on pause.
We're in this situation
where, you know,
impeachment has happened, but it
is not --
It's in this weird sort of
whatever you would call it -
-I'd like to think
impeachment is never normal.
-Yeah, it's not -- Right.
It's weird how
it's become normal.
It's like, "Yeah,
there's an impeachment.
Whatever. It's --
Live your life."
[ Laughter ]
What --
Do you feel there's any --
If you can picture a month
from now, two months from now,
any chance
the Republicans in the Senat
are going to ever
change their minds
about what the president's
been accused of?
-You know, I see the Republicans
in the Senate thus far
as spineless,
as entirely captured
by some combination
of their own right wing
and Fox News
and terrified of this president.
But there are
a whole lot of people
out there in this country.
And the more people speak up
the more people bring pressure
to bear, the more
you at least try to get some
basic fairness in this system.
You know, right now,
Donald Trump is refusing
to let people
come in and testify.
And Mitch McConnell's
backing him up on this,
who had firsthand knowledg
of what happened
in the phone call with Ukraine
and then what happened
subsequently.
And it makes no headlines
right now,
but the Trump administration has
refused lawful court orders no
that they're supposed
to produce documents.
You know, however you feel
about the president,
we got to have
some shared notion
that we all took the same oath
And that's an oath
not to an individual,
not to a political party,
but an oath to uphold
the Constitution
of the United States of America.
And that means
we need to go forward
with this impeachment trial.
We need the witnesses.
We need the documents,
just so we can have
an open and fair trial.
And then let everybody vote.
And here's the deal.
Live with that vote
for the rest of your life.
-Alright, sounds like a plan
You have a lot of those.
-I do.
-Senator Elizabeth Warren,
everybody!